rumor has it that Kevin Costner is
saying happy trails to the mega hit
Yellowstone but fans shouldn't be too
surprised the movie star has been
hinting at his departure for years
here's how
for Four Seasons and Counting Taylor
Sheridan's Yellowstone has been cable
television's Prime Time Powerhouse since
its debut in 2018 the series has
continued to set and break its
viewership records with each season
premiere in 2021 season 3 is going back
to Cali received an Emmy nomination for
outstanding production design but it was
star Kevin Costner not Yellowstone or
Sheridan who took home the franchise's
highest profile award to date a Golden
Globe for best performance by an actor
whatever the Hollywood establishment
feels about Yellowstone its Clear
reviews Costner is an actor apart from
the Behemoth whose success he helped
ensure Kevin Costner is Kevin freaking
Costner not John Dutton and while
Yellowstone may have introduced him to a
new generation of fans he's the kind of
actor who at this point in his career
falls into the category of inevitable
Discovery anyway so when sources told
deadline in February 2023 that Costner
limited his onset availability in the
second half of season 5 from 50 days
down to just one week it wasn't a huge
shock a network spokesman told the
outlet we have no news to report but it
sure seems like Yellowstone is on its
last legs the reality is that Costner
was always going to ride off into the
sunset before Yellowstone was ready to
say goodbye and rumors that he's leaving
the show to focus on his own upcoming
Western epic Horizon aren't so much
rumors as they are exactly what he's
been telling us all for years
in 2019 Costner spoke openly with Indy
wire's Ben Travers about making the
transition from film to television and
how the medium impacted his feelings
about portraying the Dutton patriarch
discussing his character's trajectory
and backstory the actor said I'm not
always privy to it sometimes with John's
Sons or wife or whatever that's been
really kept in a creative ball that's a
more vulnerable way to go through life
as an actor Costner also talked about
trying to keep a close eye on and trying
to provide some creative input regarding
potentially inconsistent behavior in the
character and how the mechanics of
shooting the series made that more
difficult he told Indie wire it hasn't
been an easy adjustment for me I don't
like it too much a major season 2
transition away from Sheridan and toured
a variety of rioters made that
adjustment even more difficult Costner's
mistrust of where his character was
headed and whether or not the audience
would follow him there and why pops up
throughout the interview and it's safe
to say that in the three plus season
since he first expressed doubts little
has been done to alleviate that mistrust
make no mistake I love Montana but I'm
doing this for our Ranch John Dutton is
still a monster that the series seems to
want to pause it as a hero and Sage
there was still time to avoid this chaos
back in season 2 when Costner first
publicly expressed his reservations in
case all that wasn't enough to prove the
actor's hesitation he later came right
out and said what his plans for the
future were and they very clearly did
not include Yellowstone
Costner showed concern about the
direction of Yellowstone in that same
2019 Indy wire interview saying if your
puts on the gas you can run into a wall
something can run quite a while if the
architecture of it is careful not
explosive but careful you can run a long
time if you make things really
compelling but that's a really hard
thing to do takes a lot of thought it's
not impulsive writing it's writing with
a lot of extended thought Costner
clearly had some issues with the
storyline of Yellowstone a series that
quite literally exploded in season three
if it's progress you seek
do not vote for me I am the opposite of
progress but if you're still doubting
customers feelings about the writing on
the show and on the wall the actor also
had this to say I'm going to play the
second half of my career out directing
but it could very well be in television
but it won't be making it up as you go
the architecture has to be there and
more about that listen a lot of my
movies are long I like the subplots I
like it when it all comes together but
not when it's made up on the Fly I don't
trust that not only has the Field of
Dreams actor expressed concern about the
series writing in the past but he's also
made his feelings about its shooting
demands pretty clear
we all love watching Kevin Costner
attempt to keep Yellowstone from flying
wildly off its axis but the actor is a
husband and father in real life too and
the logistics of shooting Yellowstone
often keep him away from his real-life
family for long grueling stretches in a
pre-season 4 interview with Good
Housekeeping the actor said I go home
every moment I can but this year we're
filming exclusively in Montana which
makes going home almost impossible when
you deal with two airplanes it's all-day
travel if it's all day travel home then
it's going to be all day travel pack if
you've never been to the Far Western
Edge of Montana where much of
Yellowstone is currently filmed there's
an important thing to note it's really
really far away from everything that
isn't the mid-eastern border of Idaho
All Things Considered it's not
surprising Costner has grown tired of
making such an enormous sacrifice
particularly when he doesn't have to
that same summer Costner told ET that
he'd originally agreed to do Yellowstone
thinking it was a 10-hour movie that's
long but not much longer than 2012's
three-part six-hour mini-series
Hatfields and McCoys for which he won an
Emmy or Verizon which will be split into
four separate movies he told the outlet
I'm down with long I understand long
really well and it was pitched to me we
were going to do one long movie
somewhere along the line they wanted to
turn it into a series and you kind of
have to look at things again they said
you want to make a long movie and I said
the idea of having a story live a little
bit longer with the characters is always
appealing to me Costner said he had his
own reasons for still deciding to sign
on but at no point did he say and I hope
to stay on the series for a very long
time he did however note that he was
quote happy for the show and everyone in
it and there's no reason to believe he's
not but the bottom line is Costner has
his own career and Life to think about
and that career already includes 21
credits as a producer and crucially
three as a director one of those
projects a little Western called Dances
with Wolves took home the Oscar for Best
Picture in 1999 and also earned Costner
and Oscar win for best director and a
nomination for best actor it's not
shocking that the actor is Shifting
Gears to do a thing he loves has done
before and has already told us he wanted
to do again what's shocking is that he
stayed on Yellowstone for as long as he
has in the first place this was never my
plan
filming for Costner's passion project
Horizon began in August 2022 Costner
told variety that the plan is to release
the Western frontier Saga as four two
hour and 45 minute movies that will come
out every three months so if you enjoy
Costner's Yellowstone mode but wish he
had more creative control you're in luck
[Music]